und dann öffentlich zu ein snap von
einer person die ich vorher nie gesehen
haben wie der gewissen foto ist diese
rotes netze kästchen das was ich einfach
200 herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen
video ja liebe leute ein zuschauer
abmessungen gewisses bild von youtube
manche leute sind damit dem gletscher
mit reflektierte andere leute denken der
youtuber wird gleiche persönlichkeiten
sind die über himmel im olymp hausen er
alle miteinander der supporters wieder
olymp und einfach den menschen recht
wenig zu tun hat und dementsprechend für
nicht immer ganz spannend zu bitten
hintergrund wird ein zubringer zu zeigen
die so ist super ich bin setze ich der
überzeugung dass sich ein halbgott wäre
oder 3d aber ich glaube die für euch mal
so zu wählen was man als youtuber
tagtäglich sieht das hat keiner die
leute lassen sich vor die kamera
irgendwas machen ihre witzchen machen
ihrem blog machen aber niemand was alles
was du gehört ein coolen an schlechten
werden ja ich denke mir gerade für
ähnlich der ausbildung serie zu machen
so youtuber die heim beziehen
wie auch immer wenn wir nicht heute
schauen wir was youtuber so an
nachrichten auf net bekommen woran denkt
er während ich mich fragen würde was
gedachten bekommen youtube chad nach
bilder oder ich dachte auch immer das
netzwerk plattform für texting war also
quasi für text schreiben sex schreiben
wie auch manche nennen das war am anfang
wahrscheinlich auch mal momentan nutzen
dabei die youtuber um mit ihrer audienz
mit ihren zuschauern zu kommunizieren so
zum beispiel auch ich und ich bekomme
ziemlich jede nachricht auf schnäppchen
machen die privatsphäre leute zu
schützen die wir die nacht schicken und
weiß nicht bloßstellen will zeige ich
euch jetzt mal nicht mein iphone screen
aber ich werde das allererste mal die
ersten fünf nachrichten live vorlegen
danach die wirklichen raus rufe euch
exakt okay die erste nachricht ist eine
antwort auf das tor von hier und da
drunter steht kommen mittel nach bonn
innenstadt bezeichnete wirklich warum
nach unten
lasst meine dritte nachricht von oben
wird ein album aufnehmen als antwort auf
diese story als klar leute teil der für
das werk von oben ist
[Musik]
[Applaus]
im beat beat beat beat
was bin ich mitten die das sind einfach
auf dem st ich weiß nicht wann hast du
ganz unerwartete dinge leute schicken
einen beat ich bin irgendwie spaß die
vor die kamera stellen versucht lustig
beseitig bin der letzte der
überseegebiets anfangen kann
aber leute die darf man mal 40 15 wieder
in textnachricht die antwortet auf dem
land formiert story ich schaue mal kurz
vor ihr ein foyer nicht weil ich bin
selbst noch geiler ich bin die ganze
zeit machen aber dann bin ich euer
haselrieder hat sein soll
das haben die ersten fünf sechs mal
chronologisch durch und die zeigen
eigentlich ganz gut was man bekommt das
netzwerk er normalerweise sind ist
einfach zuschauer als zuschauer werden
die sagen hey ihr dann ist erprobt ob
ich wirklich den tag mit filter gemacht
anzeigt mal einen hätten hätte ich mir
auch aus dass leute zeigen was die
treffen durch auch nicht was ich dazu
sagen würde aber lasst mich euch mal
eine wirklich spannende das netzwerk
geschichte erzählen und zwar bin ich an
diesem tag hier von edf in dem ich wohne
in fackeln die deutschland armbänder
wenig nach köln geflogen weichen köln
meeting entwickler köln frühmorgens ebay
der nummer 1 bis zum beispiel um halb
sechs auf oder sogar den kölner
flughafen morgens um halb neun diesem
eines netzwerk rechtlichen zeit habt ihr
wieder matches story antwort hier wieder
schick mir jemanden blieb und dann
öffentlich zu einem wert von einer
person die von ihr gesehen haben sie
direkt wissen foto video tepco keskin
öffnet materie einfach frei erzählt euch
jetzt einfach so passiert ist er für
dieses netz und w2 herrsche in
reizwäsche und versuch von quasi von
hinten fotografiert also ich hab mich da
waren leute aber so
und dann
von hinten luft von unter 4 selbst auch
hier darf ich in dem snapdragon dieser
person noch mehr bilder aber schon immer
haben sie zwei meter an eines geht los
mit deutschen behörden dann noch mehr
von dieser art von bild verliebt von
hinten dann bilder von brüsten und leute
was macht man in so einer situation
es ist halt mein morgen die seit
verpennt des todes und dann seht ihr
sowas doch wertschätzt ich hätte selbst
gar keine ahnung was ich machen sollte
da werden so reagiert ok kulturell super
ich weiß nicht wirklich in bedrängnis
das war wirklich eine extreme
erfahrungen das passiert nicht jeden tag
aber an diesem tag habe ich durchaus
vorbilder bekommt manchmal was hier aber
ist nicht die regel gut doch mal
abgehakt aber kurz weiter wir wissen wir
doch wieder wie day habt ein neues video
einen daumen nach oben verpasst ok
behinderte
zu den werbenden haben jetzt endlich zur
kenntnis liegt unterstützt sein
und ich weiß nicht wie krank ich bin
frisch getrennt
es ist doch eine begrüßt das ist so
alles fähig ungefähr bekannt wenn er auf
you tube andere menschen würden
irgendwelche serien bringen wie lukas
oder so und ich bin abläufe bekannt
hatten filter und hoch nehmen das ist
alles für dich war auf 33 2 1 wie
möglich doch da war von dem video keine
sich gefallen hat sich der um nach oben
freund da ich rechne noch weiter
vermarktete